manny ortez
asks lou once said on a podcast that
someone from the pentagon told them that
they knew
that these that this phenomenon are
demons
although lou didn't seem to believe it i
would love for lou to
expand on that well kurt let me ask you
this
um you know what what is a demon
right i think most people would would
submit to you that a demon is
some sort of supernatural being that is
based in some sort of
religious doctrine and is usually you
know malevolent to some degree
um but you know let's let's look at this
from scientific perspective
all things by definition are
supernatural until
they're they're explained so they're
normal right this cellular telephone i'm
speaking to you on
this the wi-fi signals a hundred years
ago would be completely supernatural
and yet in some parts of the world
actually if i show a picture you know of
somebody then
that's still supernatural they think the
soul is is locked in the photograph
everything is is this paranormal
until it becomes normal everything is
supernatural until it becomes natural
and that is that is the definition of it
it just means beyond our understanding
of you know what what's before us